[Music]
this pandemic has really changed
everything
but not for us we built a big dome over
the
mansion what happens when 800 of the
world's most elite footballers and their
managers
live together under one roof players
stop being polite
and start getting real this is the
champions
they say form is temporary and class is
permanent
i hope they're right because my form has
been not good
sometimes i like to pretend i'm a
cinderella
ah it fits terrible things are happening
at barcelona right now
oh you hate to see it me i love to see
it
hi uh i hope this message finds you well
just a gentle reminder that i still
exist
and would like a job
[Music]
yeah so far life in the dome is pretty
good every day us cool young bros make
crazy pool parties
the farmer's league is teaching us to
grow our own food and anything else we
need is delivered by drones
oh no my scrunchies were in there our
toothpaste
oh my breast knuckles polish whoa whoa
what's the problem lads
allow me to interpret our delivery box
has crashed into the cornfields
now for all of us out our luxury items
and as a direct result
people are losing some [ __ ] hey high
stakes rescue mission
that's o-f-t opportunity for tick-tock
come on bro you are always on tick-tock
cause i'm the king of tick-tock ugh
don't worry guys the champions will
handle this
ice fight that's fine
let's do this for canada i mean drake i
mean don't forget your fifth wheel my
dudes
it's not that we don't like lewandowski
i mean underpitch is amazing but officer
pitch
can't he just hang out with players his
own age
isn't this so lit just a bunch of cool
young dudes having a cornfield and chill
hey guys what am i what am i
i'm a pole dance
you get it paul dance because i'm polish
yeah we get it yo trill out man
okay everybody calm down you calm down
both of you alfonso's need to back off
right now uh
hey guys i think i found the box
oh [ __ ] we did it come on guys let's
celebrate with a tick tock
what's up y'all we just did a search and
rescue for this delivery box
cause if you want a job done you sent in
the champions
people never die
what is wrong with you yo my phone won't
turn on
mine either sorry how are we to get home
without our phones
what is your deal dumb cup why would you
blast us with champagne why did you even
come along
it's time to face the facts i may be
only 32 years young but i am also
32 years old sorry guys
i now realize i was being mad extra
from now on i'll just be normal robert
let's get you boys home
[Music]
[Music]
ah yes that is poop
oh look we made it or rather i finished
for you guys
whoa you did it how did you know how to
do all that stuff
this is how we got around in my day
before smartphones and fitbits
the ancient times man old people are
cool
for once we agree oh
seriously we've been going 90 minutes
what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers
live together under one roof players
stop being polite
and start getting real this is the
champion
i'm so excited to make a big difference
at buying
maybe this season we can beat barcelona
9 2.
it took a bribery scandal to get harry
maguire on the front page
me all it took was a haircut i never
cheated on my italian
citizenship test are you reading that
off of paper
[Music]
now
[Music]
well that's a bit odd everyone's been
curious about my
incredible man management of christian
politics well i
kind of told them a lie as a form of
motivation
but no i'm definitely manipulating him
okay
okay i told christian if he played
really well
this season i could maybe get him a job
in the queen's secret service
what why would you do this
beg your pardon forgot to knock being a
secret agent is
totally awesome i get to do one-liners
and climb around in the air vent
plus chelsea has so much money to burn
they bought me like all these cool new
gadgets
[Music]
before i land everybody on the coast
spot
take the mask off off me what did you do
with frank
oh that is you hey frank i fear
christian's taking the spy bit a bit too
far
if i'm to get him back on side i'll have
to call in the big guns
hello jose no sorry no time to talk
right now um
may i have zlatan's number please
yeah boy pulisic christian
pulisic huh
zlatan ibrahimovic
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god
zlatan i got your note about the secret
mission
should be cool be cool okay here is the
stupid backstory
someone is kidnapping footballers and
turning them into
human trophies oh my god
there he is grab him i've said too much
run
hey leave him alone we were in the
middle of a conversation
fresh meat how about a taste of this
hershey's chocolate
don't bother following us christian
you'll never find us at our evil lair
located on roman abramovich's yacht
which is the only boat in the harbor
100 meters that way dang it
they got away gosh now i'll
never find their evil lair hmm
where could it possibly be the boat
they're on the boat man i bet they're on
the boat
oh wow this laton statue they must have
fixed it
nose is a little small though no i've
been turned into a trophy you idiot
trophies don't talk
[Laughter]
congratulations ding dong you found me
sergio ramos who else no seriously who
else would be the bad guy
i'm gonna stop you well you can either
stop me or
save your friends please
save us yes we are so scared the choice
is yours mr pulisic
my friends or sergio ramos
my friends or
sergio ramos
my friend bro you can do both just get a
move on
right hang in there chaps i'll get you
down
wait
gee thanks christian you saved us hasta
la vista baby
your majesty oh gosh save me mr pulisic
let the queen go sergio ramos
right all right going geez what's an
overreaction this guy
oh thank you agent 10 you really gave it
110
terrific a proper spy job but that must
have been very stressful and
overwhelming enough to make you never
want to be a spy
again are you kidding i'm just getting
started
come on give me another mission give me
another mission anything anything
i now realize my liar sent christian
down a dangerous path of self-delusion
well there's only one way to sort this
with an even bigger lie
all right one more mission i need you
to go undercover as a chelsea footballer
so deep undercover that you'll never
speak of being a spy
ever again ever got it
oh that is so smart i mean
i don't get it at all but it sounds
really smart
there must have been an easier way to do
this
last one the training's a rotten egg
hope there's no lasers in there
all right please chris don't worry
that's all behind me i'm just a regular
old football player guy now
splendid
[Music]
good show agent pulisic you've made
britain proud
and frank doesn't suspect a thing and he
never will
[Music]
what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers
live together under one roof players
stop being polite
and start getting real this is the
champions
people say all i do is score penalties
but i also
dive to win those penalties oh yeah
first american to bars in jersey america
do you think it's so easy for bayern to
win the league it takes a lot of careful
planning to buy all the best players
from all the other teams
when the weather gets colder it's a good
time to reconsider florida
we've got loads of hot spots
[Music]
hurry up the ladies will be here any
minute and
last we brought you some lunch huh what
you doing
relax bro we're digging a contraband
tunnel jaden
if you want to play for manchester
united one day you can't be breaking the
rules all willy-nilly that's how you end
up slipping
slip on this
that's it you need to learn some respect
right now you have it pretty good at the
mansion but you never know
what next season brings time you see how
the other half lives
on a tour of europa house no
i can't go back you can't make me
[Music]
have a good evening
hello anyone in
here's body i do not sneak up on people
like that
welcome to europa house sorry about the
exploding light bulbs
they're incandescent
as a former juvenile delinquent i've
developed a process for getting through
the young players and setting them
straight
i'll just scare the [ __ ] out of them
right this way
up and coming talents let me be your
ghoulish guide through this house of may
we start every day here with a free
breakfast buffet
oh that's not so bad but it's also not
so good because there's no eggs
where do they get their protein here we
have our all-inclusive community fitness
center
oh nice but it's just one elliptical
that's not how you're supposed to use
that want to take a dip on our stadio
olimpico
size swimming pool we're too bad because
there's no towels
oh no they're cold check this out
[Music]
what happened to those guys oh nothing
that's just their awakens
i was trying to show you how small the
rooms is
i don't like it it's scary what's scary
this guy scariest thing about him is his
cat being addiction
i'm sorry you think i'm funny i'm funny
how
i mean funny like a clown i'm not a
clown
this guy's a clown i do birthday parties
bar and bad mitzvahs quinceaneras and
i've even done some football games look
mate you can't scare me so stop trying
it's just embarrassing oh you don't
think i'm scary
all right then i'll show you something
scary
[Music]
what is this place it's a sauna
but it never gets hot go ahead take a
look-see
[Music]
[ __ ] me what what's that anyone fancy
alone to less
stare oh
behold my envelope of doom
shall reveal your fate
ah phil food and hope of angling like so
many talents before you
till a little injury will become a
persistent one and before you know it
your contract is up for renegotiation
and you find yourself smiling through
the pain as you hold up
oh west ham shot no i don't know people
blow
bubbles at me anzu fatty they call you
the next messi
boss like beaujon befarya it all goes
wrong
you ask for more play in time but
instead you're sold to a portuguese club
with a boy back claws like i never
brought back
okay brendan i think that's enough
they're just young lads
and you jaden sanjo
your fortune is just tree letters
long em
[Laughter]
i said that's enough
[Music]
phew thanks mate you really showed me i
need to shape up
so i don't end up like you ah another
successful role modeling by jamie vardy
bon voyage lads don't forget to write to
your new mentor jamie vardy
i'll come closer if you want for me
ankle bracelet
[Music]
what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers
live together under one roof players
stop being polite
and start getting real this is the
champions
things are really crazy at barcelona
right now but
i'm not one to panic hey did you call me
every team needs an identity mine is
premier league where are they now
people keep saying my problem is that i
overthink things but
have they considered that they're not
thinking about things enough
england is so different from germany but
at least the food is still bad
[Music]
come on microchip i know you're in there
somewhere
ever since leaving liverpool people act
like i just walked off the edge of the
flat earth
but i am still the best defender of the
truth you see that
the dome is fake it's a projection
created by bill gates to control us
exhibit a
hey
oh what is this they smell like a dutch
medal full of
tulips
oh yeah
virgil you're supposed to be injured
[Music]
oh this is impossible can i help you
dejan oh
so sorry i was uh looking for masala i
miss him so bad
cool anyways good luck with that
hey uh you were running pretty fast in
there huh i guess
i mean i'm just rehabbing and you didn't
even break a sweat
i never do he can't be human he sprints
with the bad acls doesn't sweat and
still smells like a springtime in
holland
there's something stinky going on and
i'm gonna stick my nose in it
[Music]
[Music]
now this is a very good string map
[Music]
clones you shouldn't be
here dejan you were transferred
you guys you're not gonna believe it
virgil van dyke is a clone
and there's a whole army of clones in a
secret liverpool laboratory
a libertary or is it like a labra pool
oh come on guys
this is just another one of his cool
cool wacky dude theories
it's true i can prove it it's always
something with this guy
first he said there's a secret fight
club in the basement then gary bell's an
alien and now this you're a liar
and nobody believes you and even if we
did believe you nobody has a vhs player
he has a point right on point
mathematics yes yes
very very quickly these days sorry dejon
but
maybe it's time to find a new hobby
and then what if i want to convince
these guys
i will need some hard evidence
[Music]
this will do that doesn't belong to you
dejan get back i'll expose you i'll tell
the whole world what you're doing here
you shouldn't have said that now we
can't let you leave
flank him
[Music]
[Music]
again
[Music]
hello comrades it's me dejan lovren the
zenith st petersburg centre-back number
six
after a good night's sleep i now realize
there's no such thing as clones
anyways enjoy your day
um did anyone else know this lovren has
no belly button
yeah he's a weirdo
[Music]
cleaning up after everyone is exhausting
i really need a holiday
when booking my trip i sometimes wonder
what else could possibly go wrong
i mean that probably won't happen but if
my plans have to change it doesn't
matter because hotels.com has flexible
booking options
hotels.com because just in case
what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers
live together under one roof players
stop being polite
and start getting real this is a
champion
watch out santa claus is coming to town
i like my candy cane harry
hmm i suppose i should ask santa for a
real passport
what gift can you give a man who has it
all uh
humility oh how much is that i'll buy
100 humilities
[Music]
[Music]
oh i
love cristiano miss it's a time to put
aside our differences
and receive expensive gifts oh
what is this is a squishy trophy is it
uh
is it supposed to smell like this all
right all right
this one is for you robert oh cool my
dudes you should not have
oh wow it's so big it must be a
a ballon d'or but we figured you
deserved it this year anyway
hold on hold on who are you to just give
someone the ballon d'or
i mean he was the top scorer in the
bundesliga and the champions league this
year and
bayern won the travel so oh okay well if
we're all just giving the awards to our
teammates uh ronaldo
for uh having the most instagram
followers you get the ballad door
here no messing is the ballon d'or for
pulling out with bartomeu
give me that well if we're giving out
the ballon d'or
i want the leviathan award for best
goalkeeper oh like you would win
i want a grammy i want a nobel peace
prize man
let's close the trophy
here is how we will sell this we will
all get dressed up and garter in the
auditorium
and i will host this year's ballon d'or
it will be
a very tasteful ceremony as long as
everybody
follows my rules okay
[Music]
here are the rules nine men enter
one man leaves
[Music]
begin
wait i don't get it what are the teams i
am very confused
should half of us take our shirt off or
something why did you call it beyond
valendome when all the important stuff
happens inside your balan dome
yeah i guess i got carried away with all
the cool costumes in production design
and didn't really think the rest of this
concept true
okay okay new rules how about this four
main
ender two men lee those many bands too
they knock around we do this
eight times then we take those 60 men
and put their names in our pot
hey look it's snowing whoa
snowflakes oh it makes me so happy i
love the snow it's a white
christmas oh
oh i hate to be the interpreter of bad
news but that is just asbestos from the
roof
dang it guys what are we doing it's
christmas
we shouldn't be fighting over some award
we should be coming together
kevin kevin's right robert if anyone
deserves the ballon d'or
it's you man you earned it
[Music]
thank you guys that means a lot and
while i 100
deserve the award 2020 has been hard on
everybody so how about this year we all
shed the ballon d'or yeah
[Music]
everyone
[Music]
i need a break after being stuck here
forever doing other people's laundry
when booking my trip i sometimes wonder
what
else could possibly go wrong
i mean that probably won't happen but if
my plans have to change it doesn't
matter
because hotels.com has flexible booking
options
hotels.com because just in case
[Music]
is
[Music]
for more corny videos like and subscribe
to br football
if only i had teeth